western officials have said russia is
looking to double or even treble the
number of forces it has in the donbass
region as part of the next phase of its
military campaign in ukraine the
comments come after u.s officials said
they've seen indications that russian
forces are resupplying and reinforcing
troops in the region i'm joined now by
general sir richard barrons former
commander of the uk's joint forces
command uh good to talk to you
uh
general so i mean that all the focus now
seems to be on the the donbass region in
the east and southeast uh in essence it
seems to be a much narrower military
ambition for putin but nevertheless the
likelihood is a pretty intense onslaught
is that the way you see it
yes it is i think the russian armed
forces have learned some hard lessons
from the failure of their initial
campaign
and they've now decided to have rather
more modest objectives
to do one thing at once and to
concentrate all their forces so ground
forces air forces logistics commander
control on the donbass in what will
become i think by far the biggest battle
of this war so far right and i mean they
you know they prepared for some while if
you believe what you uk and u.s
intelligence were saying on the border
before the actual invasion the initial
invasion i mean what about how are they
going to prepare for this they've got
troops who are
presumably some of whom have already
fought or been fighting in ukraine who'd
be tired and and they've been retreated
to belarus or other areas of across the
border i mean how easy and how quickly
can they muster the force to do what
they want to do
so
we now know and it's a little bizarre
that actually before the invasion began
on the 24th of february most of the
russian forces weren't doing very much
more than camping because we've seen a
huge deficiency in planning and
preparation and equipment maintenance
and logistics and and training and all
of that explains some of their poor
performance so far
and you're absolutely right that at
least
25 percent of the russian ground forces
that started the war have been severely
mauled by the ukrainians are having to
be
merged and refitted
but we are nonetheless seeing more
forces being moved round to the donbass
which is about the size of switzerland
roughly and we're seeing reinforcements
arriving from elsewhere in russia and
more equipment so we are likely to see
very much larger russian forces
concentrating to assault the donbass
from the east which is where the
ukrainians are used to seeing that but
also from the north and the south in an
attempt to encircle what would be about
two-fifths of the ukrainian armed forces
right and part of this will be to
complete their
assault on the city of mario paul and uh
and and take that city
yes of course so mario paul is is part
of the donbass when it falls and it
looks like it it will in in a matter of
of uh days probably that will liberate
russian forces that are able then to
begin to move north to get behind
perhaps the ukrainian positions in the
uh in the donbass um and they'll do that
in step with the russian forces coming
down
from the north moving south and and
that's the dilemma for the ukrainian
military who've done really well in the
donbass it's the best bits of the
ukrainian uh military but they're not
going to have to deal with russians to
their east but also to their north and
their south and given all that how
likely is it that the ukrainians can
stop
president putin
taking another large chunk of of the
country
so the ukrainians have some reasons to
be confident they're in in very well
prepared positions now
they're very experienced they've been
fighting for eight years the the russian
forces as you described earlier aren't
going to be very much better prepared or
equipped so uh they they may just be
large but a bit clumsy
and the the weakness for the ukrainian
military is that they they need weapons
and money and support and they'll need
their casualties they're dealing with at
the end of what are quite extended lines
of of communication
and so the the critical part of this
battle will be can the ukrainian forces
hold on and be supplied well enough and
will the russians be any better to try
and break through stiff ukrainian
defense and is this a different sort of
warfare than we've seen elsewhere in
ukraine and will they need other weapons
and are they going to get them
so it is different it's different in
terms of of scale but some of the ground
particularly in the south of the donbass
will allow the the russian tanks and
armored infantry and armored artillery
to maneuver across open countryside
they'll be much less confined to the
roads in the way that they were around
kiev and that's what allowed the
ukrainian armed forces to ambush them so
successfully from the flanks generally
using the weapons that
the west had provided so they may
propose a very different problem
to the ukrainian military and we should
also remember the russian air force is
is currently conducting about
250 attacks a day on the donbass so
there's a significant amount of
firepower being concentrated on the
ukrainian forces to that extent it is
different
and the ukrainian military want weapons
that have more range uh are more
preciser they destroy armor at distance
and are more lethal and
they have some of that but they don't
have perhaps enough of it and there's
not much the west can do to give them
brand new equipment because they haven't
got time to learn to use it or maintain
it and well that was going to be my next
question so
my other thought is you know president
putin will want some sort of victory
won't he i mean he's he's hardly likely
to
agree to some sort of negotiation
without something he can take back to
the russian people i just wondered
finally what
do you think that victory could look
like for putin that he can
you know then say well i've got what i
want
so when the this phase of the war
started on the 24th of february the
russians had occupied about a third of
the donbass and president putin's
objective may be to take the other two
thirds that's going to be a very stiff
fight and he may think that they could
if they did that successfully and
quickly press on to the danipa river and
essentially annex a large chunk of
ukraine
that is absolutely not something that
ukraine or the west
will settle for
they'll feel that president putin
essentially has to be seen to lose this
war in the eyes of the global community
and and perhaps if he leaves this war
with the land he started with that might
be a position for a negotiation which is
one of the reasons why this is likely to
dissolve into a very difficult stalemate
right it's a pretty brutal
few weeks or or few months possibly
ahead
yes
it to do this
um given the russian performance so far
they will have to factor on on weeks
becoming months to batter their way
through these ukrainian positions unless
some game changer occurs
in in the breaking of the ukrainian
world but i think that's pretty unlikely
general barrons uh thank you very much
indeed